[Music]
you're on this show king of the Nerds
you're competing for $100,000 is that
correct and title greatest nerd of all
yeah I would just take the cash for you
how do you become a contestant on this
show um well for the last six years I've
been a professional gamer so I literally
dedicated 10 to 12 hours a day playing
video games so 10 to 12 hours a day
playing video games oh wait so did you
play at work or no Ashley I worked at a
video game store but after it was gonna
say I was a brain surgeon
we're losing the patient I'll be doing a
minute oh no no after after work I would
literally like play till I 4:00 in the
morning and then I had work the next day
at like 7:00 so I only balanced that
three hours okay
is it hard I mean you're a very
attractive likable person is it hard to
meet guys this way is it hard for you to
date if you're devoting this much time
to these games so if I go to a
competition it's a thousand guys you're
probably about seven to ten girls maybe
and also when they see you and their
pocket protectors must explode their
glasses must shatter they must lose
their minds it's you can say you could
say I guess yeah they're trash-talking
in the gaming world yes
are you a good trash talker I am so
right now you're being very nice but if
you and I were playing each other in a
game of blissful blurk soul you know
would you you you'd be really aggressive
I probably make fun of you a lot
probably I probably like hit your
shoulder and be like you're bad you know
like you don't say that yeah that's I
mean I've heard of people have said much
worse to me and on this show and I'm
talk about people that work with me
I'm censoring an event I'll probably
curse you out till you can't hear
anything in the room except for me curse
really I can't imagine you doing that I
really can't like we'd be playing and
you just let loose like that yeah I'm at
me until I cried yeah and it's
satisfying I'm not joking for you yeah
very sad that's great are there such
thing as injuries in the gaming world um
yeah I I get carpal tunnel sometimes and
there there was one point where I had
played on my joysticks for so long that
I shaved the entire top skin of my thumb
and so every time I played it was
literally like red and I'd have to like
put lotion on it every single these are
not dramatic injuries I have to break it
to you
my shoes sorry
see I can trash talk to